and donald trump to resign from their
posts as the biden administration moves
to transition
to its own nominees but the
administration is allowing two
investigations to continue correspondent
david spont has our report from the
justice department
dozens of trump-era u.s attorneys are
preparing to resign
this afternoon on a phone call acting
attorney general monty wilkinson
expressed his wish for 56 u.s attorneys
to step down
congratulations mr president the move is
not unusual
when a new administration takes power
u.s attorneys from the prior
administration
usually leave jeff sessions
in march 2017 then attorney general jeff
sessions
asked for the resignation of 46
obama-era u.s attorneys
but received heavy blowback as the
attorneys were told to leave
immediately the biden administration
leased one u.s attorney is being asked
to stay
u.s attorney david weiss of delaware who
is investigating hunter biden's business
dealings
last month president-elect biden made it
clear
the department of justice would operate
on its own free
from white house pressure i want to be
clear to those who lead this department
who you will serve
you won't work for me john durham the
u.s attorney for the district of
connecticut will resign
in that role but he'll stay on a special
counsel
to investigate the origins of the russia
probe i think president biden had a
limited role of choice here i think that
had he terminated those u.s attorneys he
would have come under attack
for making political decisions the u.s
attorneys have until the end of the
month
to resign brett david spun
at the justice department david thanks